New York Times op-ed columnist David
Brooks is on a mission to help people
live a deeper and more joyful life we
need that in his new book the second
mountain he argues that life is defined
by two mountains actually on the first
mountain people tackle personal goals
like becoming successful and on the
second people learn to look beyond
themselves and instead focus on service
to others brooke says climbing this
second mountain feel fills rather
people's lives with wonder gratitude and
hope and he joins us at the table to
discuss hello David Brooks it was a very
interesting part in the book where you
said you actually wrote this book
because you wanted to kick your own butt
what need kicking what were you looking
for writers are always working on her
you were very candid in life really
determined by the lies our culture tells
us in our lives our culture tells us if
you succeed you'll be happy or I can
make myself happy so I lived that way
and I ended up violet valuing time over
people so I was always busy I was on the
move
and so I didn't nobody could fight it in
me I had a lot of work friends weekday
friends I had no weekend friends and so
my marriage ended my kids left for
school for golf college and I was living
in this little apartment and all I was
doing was working if you went to my
drawers where there should have been
forks and knives they were post-it notes
yeah where there's human plates there
was stationery I was just living for
work
I was lonely you have this pain in your
stomach this is around 2013 yeah and you
just feel I'm in the valley I'm in the
valley and we're in a country it was a
crisis of disconnection for me and a lot
of people in this country are going
through that yeah there's a lot of
loneliness a lot of solitude so I spend
the next five years like how do I get
access so how did it compare for your
first and second mountain because you
said first mountain is about ego second
Mountain is about heart and soul so the
first mountain I had a good first
mountain yeah I'm a New York Times
columnist I get to be on PBS yeah and it
was success you would think from the
outside it was a success but it was not
feeding my soul it had turned me into
something shallow and so what I find the
people who are most joyous they go
through this process they first reject
the lies of our society that success
makes you happier I can make myself
happy if I just lose another 15 pounds
I'll be happy lie then they fall into
themselves they fall into their heart
and soul
and they go down to the substrate which
is the deepest part of themselves I have
a friend who said when my first daughter
was born
I realized I loved her more than
evolution required I always loved that
because we have this element of care
yeah and so you got to get down to that
level and then I had a community that
pulled me out I figured nobody can get
pulled out of the valley you get pulled
out by somebody who reaches in and I was
I invited over to a couple's house in DC
and they had a kid who's in the DC
Public Schools who had a friend who had
whose mom had a health and issues and
drug issues and so they said well James
can stay with us and then James had a
friend of James had a friend and when I
went over to that house in 2013 there
were 40 kids around the table 15
sleeping in the basement yeah and so I
reach out I walk in I wanted to shake
the kid's hand and the first kid I meet
in the doorway named ed says we don't
really shake hands here we hug we hug
here and I'm not the Huggies guy yeah
but I go back every Thursday for six
years and they demanded complete
intimacy from me and they really lifted
me out they've told me a better way to
live which is about relationship and not
self so David is this a road map for
people who may be on the first Mountain
or do we all have to go through the
valley and also what if some of us were
born in the valley to me you know I just
our lives are defined by our moment of
greatest adversity you know how you
react to it and I had a college student
say I haven't suffered that much maybe I
should go out and suffer I was like
don't worry yeah yeah but I found in the
moment of the valley the first thing you
learn as freedom sucks to be unattached
that's bad
we're told freedom is so great the
second thing I learned is that you can
be broken or you can be broken open yeah
and the people are broken turn angry and
resentful there's a great phrase I love
aim that is not transformed gets
transmitted to others that's good we
teach about college graduations though
because this is college graduation
season and you said a lot of times
people just get a big old empty box and
nothing do with it what I don't you like
the message of what you love because
it's all about you and you think where
are the answers that they come out of
college what are they gonna do their
lives yeah and they want to know where
do I devote myself and we say be free
and then we say oh the futures limitless
that doesn't help them make the choice
where
the authority I can go to that'll tell
me where to live my life oh you do you
look inside yourself follow your passion
80% of college students have no passion
they should be told what David they
should be told
live for relationship and that seems
easy we can all say that yeah but to see
people truly to speak from the depths of
yourself not from the surface of
yourself
these are daily challenges and in our
society we just don't treat each other
very well I have a phrase yeah I had
worse I have a phrase I've been using
which is the quality of your life is
built on the quality of your
relationships that's it I'm all of it
that's we know that and we don't do it
I've been thinking around the country
what meeting people are just great at
relationships David thank you it sounds
like they're gonna want you to speak at
a lot of graduating thank you so much
for sharing this we appreciate it the
second mountain it goes on sale tomorrow